as hundreds of thousands of Russians are
called up to fight in Ukraine some men
of military age are fleeing the country
to avoid conscription others have taken
to the streets and rare demonstrations
of resistance to the kremlin's war in
Ukraine the mobilization announced by
President Vladimir Putin earlier this
week has also led to accusations of
discrimination by Russia's ethnic
minorities they say they are being
conscripted at disproportionate rates
a few quick selfies and kisses goodbye
on a Moscow Street as this young man
heads off to a military training site
he's among thousands being called up to
serve in Russia's war with Ukraine
his wife runs over for one final hug
before he boards the bus
I'm going to defend my country that's it
how's my mood it's excellent what can
you do
of course I'm very worried but I support
my husband's decision
Russian authorities claim more than 10
000 volunteers turned up at military
enlistment offices across the country
after Vladimir Putin issued the order to
mobilize reservists this week
well some head off to fight others are
fleeing the country
soaring prices for plane tickets mean
land Crossings like this one on the
border with Georgia are jammed with
traffic they travel by car on bicycles
and even on foot to get out Georgia is
one of a handful of countries which
allows Russians to enter without visas
the matter is not that we are afraid
the matter is that we don't like the
situation I do not like what they were
doing in Ukraine
I feel sorry for our brothers I have
many relatives in Ukraine and I don't
like this at all
the order has led to several protests
across Russia hundreds of arrests and
accusations of discrimination in buriata
a mountainous Republic in eastern
Siberia some 6 000 kilometers from
Moscow activists say the Kremlin is
placing the burden of the mobilization
and the war itself on poor ethnic
minority regions
mobilization is going on it's in no way
the partial mobilization that Vladimir
Putin announced earlier
and we also think that it's a question
of Empire Putin many times has
positioned himself as an imperialist
everyone knows how Empires treat their
ethnic minorities like something that
can be used
some men in the region have reportedly
gone into hiding others have responded
to the mobilization order by Crossing
into neighboring Mongolia
crazy
we can now speak to Russia analyst
Constantine Eggert he joins us from the
Lithuanian Capital Vilnius hello to you
Constantine so it's been three days now
since Putin declared what he's calling a
partial mobilization what more do we
know about who and how many are actually
being conscripted to fight in Ukraine
well the CMR now the this mobilization
is not partial by the Rex it's not
partial it's it's very massive but there
are exemptions which were publicized by
the Kremlin Yesterday by the way to my
mind a bit late
um and they are predictable
people from State media I they put this
propaganda machine I excluded from this
draft around Co-op uh Bankers to ensure
smooth functioning a functioning of the
banking system and I.T Specialists
although there are many reports that
many IIT Specialists and many just
banking Clocks Were called up so it
seems to be a bit over belated reaction
and trying to kind of fix areas in the
uh Russian economy that are vital uh
there is I would say also a very fair
assumption that lots of most of State
bureaucrats of high level
more on most of the security services
and police and the the Russian national
guard will remain in place and will not
be called up to maintain control over
the situation in Russia itself so there
are definitely exceptions but judging by
a massive sort of a number of reports
that we get uh it seems that in all
other areas uh it is people of different
age different occupation those who serve
those who didn't serve data being
rounded up and sent to the training
camps first and I suppose to the front
after that
now there's not been much public
opposition in Russia to the war in
Ukraine is this conscription likely to
change that
I think that over time there's going to
be a certain
we are in this with this war especially
when bodies start to come back to the
families almost Frankly Speaking Marina
before that it was war on television for
the majority of Russians now it's going
to enter quite a lot of homes and the
effect eventually will be for some
families to become enraged and to say
well you know we have to kill Ukraine's
we have to avenge our relatives for the
others it will be let's get out of it as
soon as possible and probably for some
will become a case for reconsidering
what they think about this or in the
situation Russia all right that was
Russia analyst Constantine Eggert
Constantine thank you so much
thank you